get to you know the labor policies in a
minute but we've just heard from brandon
lewis he says he's got full confidence
in the sugre report despite the
allegations in the sunday times this
morning do you
well i have to say the one person that
sadly we don't have confidence in is the
prime minister we now know because of
that report that he repeatedly lied to
parliament and his response as we've
seen over the last just couple of days
has been to try and actually change the
rules that he will then be judged by
because he's seeking to water down the
ministerial code that's the big issue
here and that's what labour's focused on
because for as long as we have boris
johnson at the head of government
currently we actually aren't seeing many
of the big issues being gripped onto by
the conservatives that government
continues to be in chaos and ultimately
working people are paying the price
at the same time though you're talking
there about how boris johnson's tried to
you know change the ministerial code
that he'll be judged by it is important
to say though isn't it that the most
serious offence is a misleading
parliament that what boris johnson has
been investigated for that would still
be a resignation issue so he wouldn't
necessarily benefit himself from the
changes that he's making
well unfortunately he has not resigned i
mean ultimately that is a sanction
that's only existing found guilty
well i think most people would draw
their own conclusions frankly seeing
what's it would be a bit strange for him
to resign before the investigations
completely repeated denials
well
ultimately i think you're seeing many
conservative mps themselves having taken
that decision not enough of them i would
say but when it comes to the reform of
the ministerial code you know i think
the difference is very very clear you've
got boris johnson having removed the
words integrity accountability honesty
even from the forward to that code as i
say he has watered down the sanctions it
used to be previously the case that any
breaking of the ministerial code would
be a resignation issue neither other
sanctions that have been put in there
even just apologizing we're surely that
would be the very first thing that we
would expect that's not a sanction
that's just what ministers should do as
a function of course if they're found to
have broken the rules so we will be
forcing a vote on this we think that
ultimately politics should be clean they
should be a force for good we should
have all politicians held to high
standards that's why we're calling for
that vote
okay i'm keen to talk a little bit about
the cost of living at crisis because we
saw as i said in the introduction to you
we saw the conservative response uh this
week and it was widely welcomed you know
the ifs called it a big expensive
package which is hugely redistributed
taking from high earners and giving to
the poor the resolution foundations that
it rightly prioritizes those hit hardest
by the cost of living crisis you must
welcome the action that's been taken
well of course after five months of
calling for that windfall tax finally we
are relieved that the government appears
to have listened at least on that
subject but we are concerned that there
doesn't seem to be any plan now to deal
with the causes of that cost of living
crisis yes some action to deal with its
symptoms that we've called for as i said
for many months but not action to deal
with its causes i mean again labour's
called for many many months now for a
home insulation program that would take
400 pounds off people's bills not just
this year but in subsequent years into
the future as well again the other
measures that we need to see being taken
for our energy security labor's called
for example for a doubling of onshore
wind for tripling of solar and for an
end to the government's delay on new
nuclear we need those measures to be
taken urgently because they will deal
with the causes of some of this cost of
living crisis and not just the symptoms
you know it seems with this government
they tend to be dragged kicking and
screaming to action at the last minute
we need to see those longer term plans
now
it's interesting isn't it because i do
sometimes feel listening to labor um
that you want the government to go a
little bit more quickly on things that
it's already you know doing when it
comes to nuclear you're sort of saying
that they want to speed it up but the
government has committed to a nuclear
strategy if the big idea is you know
homes insulation that's something that
politicians have spoken about for an
awfully long time i mean you're head of
labour's policy review that was launched
in june 2021 so it's been running for a
year now we're currently facing
an absolute cost of living crisis
inflation at a 40-year high potentially
the biggest drop in living standards
since records began what is the single
transformative idea that you've come up
with in this year-long policy review
well we've come up with many many ideas
if people are particularly interested
they can look at our reports on the
labour website and i have to say that
the core idea for labour is right now
when it comes to that cost of living
crisis as i said not just dealing with
the symptoms we set out that windfall
tax policy it took the government five
months to contemplate it they said that
it was unconservative they said they
wouldn't enact it they've been dragged
kicking and screaming to put it into
place but we're saying right we've got
to deal with those causes as well you
know we just talked about energy
security and labor's plan there yeah
just to come in because i did ask you
the one for growth
sorry to interrupt i did ask just going
to transformative policy what is it
well i was just going to to say and
sorry it's difficult when we're not in
the same place but i was going to say
when it comes to growth when we've had
such low growth under conservative leg
governments compared to under
previous labor governments that we're
very clear we've got to buy make and
sell
more in our country and that's what
rachel reeves has been setting out if we
do that then we can build growth back up
again because we've had far too low
levels of economic growth that's holding
back people's living standards and we've
set out exactly how we would be
delivering that so it really is labour
that's the party of ideas now the
conservatives have been dragged along in
the wake of what labour has been setting
out there and that's a big problem
because people are right up against it
right now and they need to see a
government that's on their side they
don't have that at the moment okay i
just want to move on to your women and
equalities of brief to end
stella cruci the labour mp said in an
interview with telegraph yesterday do i
think that women were born with penises
yes do you agree with her
well no i don't agree with her
biological
females
obviously aren't of course there are
also
trans women who've made a transition in
their gender but sex is not the same as
gender but i would say that obviously i
have a huge amount of respect for my
colleague stella crissy she's done a
huge amount of campaigning for women but
on that issue around biology um i do
have a different opinion
um it's interesting this debate and you
know the last thing you want to do is
just to kind of try and get the kind of
shock questions or anything like that in
but there is a genuine debate that's
being had on what trans policy means
more widely so ella bravaman the
attorney general gave an interview with
the times this weekend where she was
speaking about how school should
accommodate trans pupils and of course
this is a live debate you know the
education secretary is drawing up
guidance uh on single sex spaces so she
was asked whether pupils who were born
male should be able to use girls
lavatories or changing facilities
and she said i would say to the school
that they don't have to and that they
shouldn't they shouldn't allow that
child to go into girls toilets i think
protecting single sex spaces for
biological females and biological males
is really important particularly in
schools
what's your position on that
well of course it was labour that
created the equality act that provides
the legal
background for those single sex spaces
where they're needed but i have to say i
find this incredibly frustrating i mean
as you mentioned the government said
that it would produce guidelines to help
schools to help teachers on these issues
they haven't produced those guidelines
instead you've got ministers for taking
up their time talking about these
different issues sounding off on them
not providing those guidelines and quite
frankly our attorney general when she's
presiding over such low levels record
low levels of prosecutions for rape and
actually making the situation worse now
by allowing actually the notes from
counselling sessions for rape victims to
be used to attack the credibility of
those victims i think she should get a
grip on that issue and focus on it and
ultimately if she's concerned about the
situation
in school she should be getting her
education colleagues to hurry up and
produce the guidelines that they said
they would provide because all children
all children need to be safe in school